poste et l écoute pour vous faire
plaisir ghislaine je vais vous offrir
une petite balade dans l'île de ré que
vous connaissez bien
je suis sûr que vous connaissez
l'histoire des ânes en culotte de l'île
de ré denis culotte à carreaux rouge et
blanc pour part pour protéger des
moustiques les les ânes qui allait
chercher le sel dans les marais salants
alors ils vont faire leur réapparition
un peu un retour aux moustiques
non non on n'espère pas les années en
culotte rouge et blanc un retour aux
sources à un moment où est bien où on
s'apprête à sacrifier au folklore débat
qui a tool qui de couture dans un
réfectoire d'une école de l'île de ré
aux coupes et ont cousu vichy retour on
rentre des années 50
pas vraiment plutôt à la mode animalière
du début du siècle celle où les haines
dorée et est culotté voulais pas rester
tranquille si je me dis mougins autour
d'eux ils auraient prévu le mont d'or
tandis que là bas avec laquelle les
empêcher de la rencontre de deux
générations autour des culottes et
hystérie le cours moyen première et
deuxième année du bois-plage-en-ré a
célébré cet animal un après-midi de
classe par semaine
pratique pour une culotte prêt-à-porter
ch
séance d'essayage travaux manuels défilé
dans la cour d'école
le jury distribue les bons et les
mauvais points c est ce que tu le trouve
plus beaucoup naturel prix dit tu fais
une par contre ça pour être cage mais
alors c'est si j'étais à la place d'un
match soit serré parce que ça me ferait
jamais la commune a comme détecté à
savoir petite poupée
ouais il est baptisé bo à cette époque
là vous aviez toujours du soler l'île de
ré transition passe il passe